[Music]
on this Wednesday night navigating
negotiations between WestJet and its
Pilots the CEO's optimism a deal can be
reached we are working around the clock
the fresh threat against homes in
Alberta's Wildfire Zone plus concerns
for troops extinguishing the flames
dire prediction about the planet there's
no return back to the good old days with
the next five years could bring
tense night what Harry and Megan call a
nearly catastrophic run-in with the
paparazzi
and unprecedented view the Titanic like
you've never seen her before
[Music]
Donna Friesen good evening and thanks
for joining us thousands of WestJet
passengers are still wondering if the
flights they've booked for the long
weekend are going to take off talks
between the pilots Union and WestJet are
still underway but the strike deadline
of 5 a.m eastern time on Friday is
looming the two sides appear to remain
far apart on key issues especially wages
I'll talk to the CEO of WestJet in just
a moment but we begin with Anne gabiola
who has our top story tonight
I think we have to be preparing for a
very disrupted weekend and maybe a
summer that will follow through as well
with disruption new details about what's
happening behind closed doors Global
News have changed a memo sent to Pilots
by westjet's vice president of flight
operations just hours after the union
issued the strike notice and the company
countered with a lockout notice
it says Pilots rejected total
compensation of 350 thousand dollars for
a wide body Captain which make up most
of westjet's Fleet 300 000 for a narrow
body Captain it goes on to say WestJet
Pilots would have the highest narrow
body first officer and Captain TOP Step
wage rate in Canada the union tells
Global News the figures are
cherry-picked we have members that our
first officers and captains of all
levels of the seniority that fly
different types of airplanes and this
certainly doesn't paint the picture of
all the members that we are trying to
represent here the union says its Pilots
are paid 45 percent of the North
American average according to the U.S
Bureau of Labor the median annual wage
for airline pilots co-pilots and flight
Engineers was a little more than 200 000
U.S in May 2021 this Human Resources
Professor tells Global News a senior
captain of a wide-body aircraft at Delta
can make nearly 600 000 U.S he says the
WestJet Pilots are in a strong position
given demand for Pilots or around the
world WestJet is essentially reaping
what has been sown in the industry more
generally as a consequence of
liberalization earlier this month Air
Canada Pilots voted to join Alpa the
world's largest Pilots Union on the
heels of its successful negotiations
with U.S carriers airline pilot
Association basically concluded some 30
to 35 percent wage increases for U.S
carriers and U.S Pilots so they're
saying that we can probably get the same
thing for westjet's Pilots key issues
remain compensation working conditions
and job security but both sides say
they're committed to coming to a fair
agreement in time to avert a strike on
Friday Donna okay and gaviola in Toronto
thanks and with me now is WestJet CEO
Alexis Von hernsberg thanks for speaking
with us today I know you've described
the demands of the pilots as
unreasonable what are they asking for
that's unreasonable well let me start
from the other end we have made a very
reasonable and but also very generous
offer which is basically raising their
their wages by a double digits
percentage and also addressing a lot of
the concerns that they have so overall
the entire negotiation is around a scope
so job security basically it's around
working conditions and it's around wages
right but you did say in a tweet that
you thought that their expectations are
unreasonable yeah the Pilot's
expectations are pretty high so they
compare themselves to the Canadian
Pilots are comparing themselves to their
U.S peers and in the US current current
pilot contracts actually pay double of
what is being paid in Canada and part of
this is exchange rate but part of this
is that's this is just a very different
market and they have publicly said that
they would like to close this Gap and if
you want to close a gap that's uh times
two then you can imagine how how big the
jump may be that will take them to where
they uh would like to get and that's
just in this environment where we are
not a reasonable expectation that one
can have there are two things an airline
cannot do without airplanes and Pilots
we're on the eve of a long weekend a
busy travel summer are you really in a
position to be bargaining hard with the
pilots Union
so first of all I'm here to make a deal
and the same is true for the pilot Union
and we are having a federal
mediators here we had the minister of
Labor here today so we are working
around the clock in this hotel near
Toronto where I'm currently am in order
to come up with a deal and that's uh my
first priority that we can do that and I
still see a path
um but I think both sides have to be
reasonable and really want to come up
with a deal
where are you now
while the Gap is still substantial but
there's also magic of the last 48 hours
and I have a significant hope into the
magic of the last 48 hours but in the
end there are limits to what we can do
we are generous we we want to come up
with a deal which makes sense for our
valued Pilots but also safeguards the
long-term future of our company and all
of its 15 000 employees so we cannot we
can we cannot risk the long-term future
of the company to avoid a short-term
one-off cost of a strike and and
therefore we have to find a resolution
that makes sense for both parties and
not just for one and what's your message
to passengers who have lights books who
are wondering if they're going to take
off my first message is uh that I'm feel
very sorry for the fact that our guests
have been caught in this conflict uh
that I think is absolutely unnecessary
my second message is I'm here to come up
with the deal to protect our guests
travel over the May long weekend we
don't want to disrupt this travel
my sub message is there is nothing
certain in life and I while I do the
best I can to come up with a deal I
can't promise that we can come up with a
deal and if labor action happens then
gas travel will be disrupted so I can I
can suggest that it is probably a
prudent thing to do to think about
Alternatives and then plan for the worst
but hope for the best all right Alexis
Von hernsberg WestJet CEO will keep
watching this thanks for speaking with
us
thank you very much in Alberta smoke
from the wildfires is blowing South
triggering a special air quality
statement for most of the province some
evacuation orders have now been lifted
people are able to go home some of them
but some are discovering damage and
looting on their property nithu garcha
is in Fox Creek Northwest of Edmonton
neither what's the situation there
yeah Donna you can see the police
blockade and road closure behind me here
in Fox Creek the community of about 2000
is now in its 12th day of evacuation
Alberta Wildfire officials tell us
persistent hot dry conditions mean fire
activity in this area is flaring up
foreign
Fox Creek long-haul drivers looking for
gas along Highway 43 are turned away
with few options for fueling up town
officials say Thick Smoke in the area is
making it difficult to monitor the
wildfire's distance but winds have
pushed the Flames towards the community
heavy smoke rolled back into communities
like Valley View about 300 kilometers
Northwest of Edmonton Wednesday after
some clearer skies on Tuesday
in Grand Prairie many people at this
evacuation Center are worried about
their homes still under threat from the
fires there's been around 30 houses it's
not a final number we just know 30
structures right now could go up some
also lost personal belongings not to the
fires but to looters Alberta RCMP say
new drone technology has helped lead to
arrests across the municipal District of
Greenview there have been 28 reported
instances of break and Enter or trespass
with 12 individuals arrested RCMP have
also arrested one person in connection
to a fire scare in Grand Prairie Monday
large Flames broke out near the hospital
in what officials say is suspected arson
there's some active investigations in
regards to potential uh suspicious
starts there is some good news in
Drayton Valley a town of about 7 000
where some of the residents have been
allowed back home for Crews including
Canadian Armed Forces members helping to
fight the Wildfire near that Community
burnout is a concern we're still finding
hot spots in the area of operations
pretty continuously the challenge at
this point honestly is there's a lot of
work to do for our soldiers and so I'm
really monitoring their well-being this
is a marathon and not a Sprint Canadian
Armed Forces they have approximately 400
people deployed in to assist the
province in their response RCMP members
from BC Saskatchewan and Manitoba are
also in the province as the federal
government looks beyond Canadian borders
for further support to help protect
communities like Fox Creek still socked
in by smoke
emergency preparedness Minister Bill
Blair says with a significant number of
wildfires also burning in BC
Saskatchewan and Northwest Territories
Ottawa is reaching out to countries
who've supported Canada in the past
including the U.S Mexico
for more help
how could drag on all summer
Global News Fox Creek Alberta
the World Meteorological organization
keeps a close eye on weather extremes
and its scientists say the world is
almost certain to experience new record
high temperatures in the next five years
it estimates there's a 66 percent chance
of reaching the crucial 1.5 degree
increase in global temperatures Jackson
prosco explains what the likely
consequences of that will be
spring has upended weather Norms
shattering records for heat drought and
catastrophic rainfall the U.N warns
there's far more to come in the next
five years when the world will all but
certainly breach an average of 1.5
degrees of warming at least temporarily
it's practically sure that we will see
the warmest year on record during the
coming five years 1.5 degrees Celsius is
the threshold where scientists believe
the worst impacts of climate change will
come into effect
it's also the target countries pledged
not to exceed as part of the 2015 Paris
climate Accord we haven't been able to
to limit the warming so far and and we
are still moving in the wrong wrong
direction human-made climate change
coupled with a developing El Nino cycle
are responsible for pushing the planet
into this Uncharted climate territory
the last Global heat record in 2016 was
also during El Nino but now the un says
the Earth is firmly on track to
permanently exceed the warming threshold
by the 2030s unless there's drastic
action on emissions it is an alarm Bell
for the planet we're absolutely not on
track to limit warming to 1.5 degrees C
or less right now Canada could see some
of the most dramatic impacts of a hotter
world the Arctic is warming faster than
anywhere else while scientists warn
there's going to be less rain in places
like southern Europe where crops May
wither and die our climate models
computer simulations are predicting that
for the future there will be less rain
falling in this already drought stressed
area the next five years could bring the
most dramatic and irrefutable evidence
of looming climate catastrophe the U.N
warns there's no turning back humans can
only hope to limit future damage the
best that we can do is to phase out
these negative trend Jackson Brosco
Global News Washington
a Canadian man caught recruiting for an
Al-Qaeda linked terrorist cell has been
granted day parole in 2014 heva Eliza
day admitted guilt and was sentenced to
24 years in prison today in an emotional
hearing he told a parole board he has
abandoned terrorism and wants to be
released to a Toronto halfway house Eric
Sorensen looks at his case
just two years after hiva Eliza day
became a Canadian citizen he began
plotting an attack on the country that
welcomed him in 2009 he went to an
Al-Qaeda training camp in Afghanistan
then returned and recruited two others
but police were tipped off and in Ottawa
and London Ontario they swooped in and
found bomb making manuals and other
devices investigators have seized more
than 50 electronic circuit boards
designed specifically to remotely
detonate IEDs wiretaps had recorded
Eliza day
effort to be part of them together
at trial Elizabeth considered the
ringleader admitted his guilt now after
serving close to 13 years of a 24-year
sentence Eliza days been granted day
Parole in the hearing he cried and
apologized to Canadians I promise you I
will be a law-abiding citizen Ms
behuddin Ahmed was also convicted and
paroled four years ago a third suspect
was found not guilty Abby Corb an expert
in extremism often spoke with Eliza day
when he was in prison and believes de
parole is a good first step when I was
working with him he was well on the Road
to Redemption if he's closely monitored
and has restrictions then
you know he people shouldn't be
concerned but some are concerned that
those once motivated by extreme ideology
could reoffend in a separate case Kevin
Omar Muhammad completed a sentence on
terrorism charges but after his release
was arrested again with Al Qaeda
literature and bomb making manuals
stored on his phone Correctional
Services Canada does not offer
de-radicalization programs for those
convicted of terrorist-related crimes
programs to ensure a smooth transition
back into society are what's needed says
this expert where the problem lies is in
the collaboration and partnership
between practitioners on ground in
society
and the correctional service so there is
this void it's a Pity that we in Canada
don't have that because the
de-radicalization and disengagement
program can help people for when they do
get out experts say the correction
system needs new measures because more
people convicted of extremist acts will
be released in the years ahead Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
Canadian tourist has been killed on
Mexico's Pacific Coast Mexican
government officials say A man was
killed in a Beach town in Oaxaca local
media Reports say he was found with a
bullet wound in a car in a neighborhood
not commonly visited by tourists the
Canadian government says Consular
officials are in contact with local
authorities he is the second foreign
tourist to be killed in the state this
week Canadian travelers to Mexico are
being warned to exercise a high degree
of caution
prime minister Justin Trudeau's push for
Canada and South Korea to be BFFs coming
up the deals the country's just signed
plus where they don't see eye to eye
prime minister Justin Trudeau has signed
new deals on critical minerals and
economic security in South Korea the
visit is being billed as an effort to
step up cooperation between Canada and
South Korea and reduce economic
dependency on China a Kenzie gray
reports
a warm welcome and a selfie from South
Korean legislators as Justin Trudeau
made his debut in Seoul I am proud to be
the latest Canadian to celebrate this
friendship
but I'm here to tell you that it's no
longer enough to be friends
we need to be the best of friends in his
speech to the National Assembly the
Prime Minister said he took his
relationship to the next level with
South Korean president Yun Suk Yul
welcome my friend assigning deals to
allow an additional 8 000 young people
to study and work in both countries each
year
a framework on critical minerals and
energy security what a pleasure to see
you again a key topic when Trudeau met
with Korean Executives who hope they can
replace Chinese medals with Canadian
Supply there's opportunities right now
where Canada is a strong stable reliable
partner to many many friends around the
world it's a place where good things get
done but outside of those two agreements
other concrete measures on how to grow
their relationship with sparse the South
Korean leaders saying the two countries
increased intelligence sharing to their
private defense industry but wouldn't
give any other details
foreign
and despite saying they're besties
there's still a major difference on
Justin Trudeau's feminist first foreign
policy Eunice blamed low birth rates in
Korea on feminism and said that systemic
gender discrimination doesn't exist in
South Korea despite having the largest
pay gap between men and women among
developed countries Yoon said Trudeau
didn't raise the issue but did discuss
child care and gender equality but I did
a highlight
that one of the most important things
is to ensure that all citizens get to
participate in the success of our
economies the prime minister's final
event in South Korea will be to walk the
cap young Trail the site of a key battle
during the Korean War where 10 Canadians
died after that Justin Trudeau's off to
Japan for the G7 Donna okay Mackenzie
gray in Seoul South Korea thanks
damage and Devastation ahead deadly
floods drenched parts of Northern Italy
[Music]
some daring helicopter rescues in
Northern Italy today after devastating
floods left at least eight people dead
and thousands of others homeless some
areas have received half their average
annual rainfall in just 36 hours and
nearly two dozen towns are inundated
with flood water local Mayors call it
catastrophic before this the region had
been dealing with severe drought
Sunday's Formula One race in Imola has
been canceled and more rain is forecast
for the next few weeks
there's been a lot of talk today about
an incident in New York City a
spokesperson for Prince Harry and his
wife Megan claim they were involved in a
near catastrophic car chase by
aggressive paparazzi
[Music]
it's alleged it happened after the
couple along with Megan's mother left an
awards ceremony in Midtown Manhattan
around 6 p.m last night the three
reportedly switched Vehicles getting
into a taxi in an attempt to lose the
paparazzi in a statement a spokesperson
said the Relentless Pursuit lasting over
two hours resulted in multiple near
collisions involving other drivers on
the road pedestrians and two NYPD police
officers there's some skepticism about
that
I would find it hard to believe that
there was a two-hour high-speed chase
the 10-minute Chase is extremely
dangerous in New York City we have a lot
of traffic a lot of movement a lot of
people are using our streets
the NYPD says there were no reported
collisions injuries or arrests the cab
driver is quoted as saying the car was
being followed but he wouldn't call it a
Chase Harry has said in the past he
blames the paparazzi for the death of
his mother Princess Diana she was killed
in 1997 when the car she was in crashed
in a Paris tunnel while being pursued by
photographers
Titanic tour next the first full-size
scan of the world's most famous
shipwreck
the Titanic still sits on the floor of
the Atlantic Ocean almost 4 000 meters
beneath the surface now more than a
century after it sank the first
full-size 3D scan of the world's most
famous shipwreck has been revealed it
was created using more than seven
hundred thousand images collected during
an expedition to the site of the wreck
last summer researchers say it's one of
the first major steps to driving the
Titanic Story towards evidence-based
research and not speculation about what
happened more than fifteen hundred
people died when the ship struck an
iceberg on its maiden voyage from
Southampton England to New York City in
1912. and that is global national for
this Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen
tonight's your candidate is Agassi
British Columbia beautiful shot we'd
love to see your Canada please email it
to viewers at globalnational.com and
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
thank you